[Music]
google cloud enables you to migrate
virtual machine instances custom images
or disks from on-premise environments or
other cloud providers to compute engine
there are several ways you can migrate
workloads to compute engine
including
migrate for compute engine
importing virtual appliances or
importing virtual disks
in this video we will focus on how to
import virtual appliances and virtual
disks
migrating virtual appliances and virtual
disks is best suited for small number of
vms if you want to migrate a large
number of vms check out migrate for
compute engine
the first scenario will cover importing
virtual appliances followed with virtual
disks
virtual appliance is a package that
contains hardware configuration and disk
images for a vm instance
before you start a migration you should
always
check if the os is supported for
migration
check if the os is compatible for
migration by running the precheck tool
choose if you will use your own license
keys or if you will use google cloud's
pay as you go model
set up a storage bucket grant iam
permissions for the import operation
after we complete the migration
prerequisites we will do one of the
following
either export the vms into ova or ova
format and upload them to a gcs bucket
or export the virtual disks which are in
vmdk or vhd format
to a gcs bucket
check out this documentation for more
information on uploading files to a gcs
bucket
for this example we have already
uploaded an ovf package and one boot
disk to a bucket
next we import the ovf files into a
compute engine
we can import machine images through a
gcloud command or a compute engine api
we have two options when importing
we can either create an instance
directly while importing the ovf or
import it as a machine image then create
a new instance from that image
the command on the screen
imports a virtual appliance directly
into an instance
the source uri here is the path to the
ovf directory
there you go we have successfully
imported an instance from a virtual
appliance
the command shown here creates a machine
image from this virtual appliances and
these machine images can be used to
create instances later on
there are many flags available for
custom settings
such as
by ol to specify bring your own license
model
project to specify the project you want
to import this image
zone to specify the zone in which image
to be imported
guest os features
to enable one or more supported features
you can explore more of these flags in
the documentation
there you go we have successfully
imported the machine image from the
virtual appliance
next we will cover how to import virtual
disks
virtual disk is a file used by virtual
machines that emulate an actual disk
storage device migration prerequisites
remains the same for importing virtual
disks
we can import virtual disks using
google cloud console
google cloud cli and compute engine api
in google cloud console go to create an
image page
specify a name of the image under source
select virtual disk
browse the virtual disk file
specify the operating system that is
available
in the imported disk
then click create to import the image
congratulation we have successfully
created an image from the virtual disk
check out the documentation to learn
more about compute engine migration
paths
[Music]